Peter crass author of how do you
pronounce it
Carnegie emphasis on the middle syllable
not Carnegie no no and if you go into
New York City and you go to Carnegie
Hall they'll pronounce it Carnegie and
it when he was growing up his nickname
was neg so that that kind of settles the
dispute right there
helmut how long did you spend with this
man debt in order to get this book
written start to finish two and a half
years and it was solid through every day
I was completely dedicated to it how
many books have you written well this is
my my first biography I did a series of
business anthologies that were classic
writings by the greats including Andrew
Carnegie which is when I first became
familiar with him why Carnegie he is
incredibly complex he he typifies the
Titan of the Gilded Age and I think the
American public is still fascinated with
that time the recent Morgan and
Rockefeller biographies are evidence of
that and if you're looking for a
character to work with as a biographer
Carnegie's fantastic because he was so
complicated he had an incredible
internal conflict and his behavior was
often so contradictory that you just
want to dig in and and find out what was
driving this man your own relative did
what with Carnegie at one time
my great-grandfather worked in a
Carnegie mill the Duquesne mill right
outside of Pittsburgh and he he was a
skilled laborer who worked in the
furnaces changing the lining this was
back he lived from 1872 to 1931 so most
of his tenure there was post Carnegie
but even post Carnegie that the life as
a steel worker was tough anything passed
on in the family no you know I actually
didn't know about that till I started
this project and an aunt came to me and
said you're not going to believe this
you've got a great grandfather who
worked
a mill and so there really isn't
anything passed on except stories and
and they're not pleasant stories as a
matter of fact my great-grandfather tend
to imbibe to soothe his pain and so most
of the story Center out is drinking what
were some of the stories about working
there just that you know it just ground
him down so much that that when he came
home he was just so tired bitter
he had they had at least ten kids and so
you can imagine working in a mill all
day coming home to that kind of brewed
so it was tough you say in your book
that john d rockefeller is the richest
man in history in the united states two
hundred billion dollars based on today's
money that's right there was an
economist who did an article for the new
york times back in 1999 and that's where
i lifted this information from and he
asked he didn't use the CPI index he had
a funky formula to estimate what what
these titans would be worth today and he
put Karaka filler at a little over two
hundred billion he put carnegie it a
little over one hundred billion and then
we'd have gates that you know mid 40s
billions depending on his stuff right
before we talked about mister carnegie
go let's go to the end and ask about
what he did with his wealth where can we
see things today that carnegie spent his
money on in this country well there's a
number of major foundations still in
existence that he created that the
primary one is the carnegie corporation
in new york you've got the Carnegie
Institution in Washington DC which which
funds a lot of scientific work you've
got the Carnegie Institute out in
Pittsburgh which is an incredible
facility that that includes a museum art
museum a museum of natural history
library you've got carnegie mellon which
became carnegie mellon I believe in the
50s or 60s merged right University and
then over in Scotland you've got a
number of foundations still in existence
so his legacy is
felt by literally millions of people how
big is something like the Carnegie
Carnegie Foundation well that the
Carnegie Corporation in New York has a
fun now at about two billion dollars and
giving an example of the work they're
doing several years ago they gave
fifteen million dollars to urban
libraries which is exactly what Carnegie
himself would want them to be doing
today because libraries were his
centerpiece and he felt that they would
best uplift the masses and by giving
that kind of money to urban libraries
certainly fits right in with what he
wanted how many libraries would not be
in existence today in this country
without his money well in let in the
world it would be close to 3,000 I'm not
sure what the number is in the US now
you have to realize some of those
library buildings become decrepit they
were torn down replaced however there
there were close to 3,000 communities
you said there's a 20 I don't know where
you got this for you but 27 percent of
them don't have his name on that's right
that's 27 percent have the name of the
rest don't that's right because there's
there's ass misconception that the
Carnegie forced his libraries on
communities and wanted his name on those
buildings sort of the Ramseys two-factor
you know where he built temples all over
Egypt and slapped his name on him their
comparisons been made but in fact that's
not true
because it was the communities that
would come to him it was mainly women's
clubs ministers town councils would come
to Carnegie request a museum they'd have
to fill out an application it have to be
okayed by Carnegie secretaries and never
was his name
required to be on the building in fact
the state of Indiana which which
received numerous libraries not one had
his name on the building where did you
go to get the information for the book
and is there anything new in here well I
went to Pittsburgh obviously the Heinz
History Center there has boxes of
carnegie papers so does the Library of
Congress
New York City and then over in Scotland
and as far as new material goes it's
there's an interesting story Henry Clay
Frick who was obviously a key partner in
this this business of his it's had kept
all his papers as well and the Frick
family over the years is bickered over
whether his papers should be in
Pittsburgh or whether they should be in
New York as a result scholars often
don't have access to those papers but
there was a window of opportunity in the
90s and a British scholar by the name of
Kenneth Warren got a hold of them and
put them in a book of his called
triumphant capitalism so I was able to
access those papers which through his
book of course that prior biographers
didn't have access to and by weaving
them into what was already out there you
start to get a different picture of
Carnegie during certain events you get a
fuller portrait of him also the last
biography was in 1970 since then we've
got all these electronic databases these
incredible search engines so by using
those I was able to find papers in other
families completely unrelated to the
Carnegie business but that referred to
Andrew Carnegie so again it gives a
fuller picture of him and some of these
kind of peripheral papers actually are
even better to go to because they
weren't out there for posterity sake
they were never meant to see the light
of day so you get a more honest picture
of them at times you say he was born in
Scotland in 1835 and died in Lenox
Massachusetts in 1919 when he died how
much money did he have 25 million
dollars based on the dollar back then
yes right and Andy right and in his will
every penny went to various institutions
and nothing was left for his wife and
daughter who had already been taken care
of at that and at that point he'd
already given away 330 340 million
dollars jump into a letter in the middle
of your book to his fiancee at this time
by the way how
did he marry Hillary married once and
when did he marry he was 51 so we're
looking at 1887 how old was she she was
about 20 years his junior in this letter
he says our parents are better and I
have always known what you said recently
was true to leave your mother you could
not think of it nor could I mine mother
seems really better it's miraculous
I trust yours is also better everything
does hang upon our mothers with both of
us our duty is the same to stick to them
to the last I feel this every day
Wow there's been some debate whether or
not he promised his mother not to marry
until she died because they lived
together you know right up until her
death and in fact I'm certain that that
that promise was made to her because she
died in the fall of 86 and he married in
April of 87 and everything he did was
for his mother you can't discount that
he was driven for her to ride in a fancy
carriage for her to live in a fancy
mansion for her to have servants why
growing up in Scotland that was a period
called the hungry 40s and there was an
incredible economic downturn his father
was a handloom Weaver and the Industrial
Revolution was was kicking off in
Britain before it reached here and he
eventually found himself out of work
the steam powered looms took over and it
was his mother who came to the rescue
she started mending shoes at night she
started working during the day in a
little grocery shop she set up in the
front window of their house and she
became his heroine his father basically
faded completely from the picture and he
dedicated his life to her to reward her
for what she had done here's the house
do you say he was born in that's right
and that actually he lived in half of
that house it was a duplex
and I visited there and just to give you
an idea of what the actual size is if
you took eight paces across and in six
paces across the other way that was
basically your floorplan where is it
it's in Dunn firm land Scotland which is
just north of Edinburgh
what's the town like it's very grey its
nickname is the grey old tune and it was
a manufacturing center that that's
certainly seen better days you've also
brought along this picture and this
picture is in the book right I just
wanted to give you a contrast of where
he started and where he ended up because
we all talk about Andrew Carnegie being
the classic rags to riches story and in
a certainly those two photos tell that
story where is this that's Skibo castle
which is in the highlands it's about an
hour north of Inverness so what year did
he come to the United States 1848 how
old was he he was 12 why did he come
here well the situation the economic
situation had gotten so bad and done
firm 'ln that that his parents felt they
had no choice and again it was his
mother who was the driving force for
this move his father would have been
very happy to struggle along I think in
Dunfermline but they were looking for a
better life and they moved to where they
the town is called it was called
Allegheny City it's now the north side
of Pittsburgh and in those days the
nickname was slab town and you said that
his mother worked on shoes right over in
Scotland her here in Scotland and then
so they come to the United States and
Andrews father William tries his hand
again at hand loom weaving but there's
just no market for it he briefly takes a
job in a cotton factory doesn't last
long at all so his mother again steps
into the void and she starts mending
shoes for a English neighbor whose last
name is Phipps and again she saves the
day and that the Phipps family became
very tight with the Carnegie family in
fact Harry Phipps who was the the son
the shoemaker became a lifelong partner
of Carnegie Andrew Carnegie made his
money how in a series of phases everyone
thinks of Andrew Carnegie is a steel
magnate but you really have to go back
to the 1850s to start tracking his rise
and you have to think that realize that
he didn't get into steel until the mid
1870s long before he was in steel he was
an investor and he bought stocks bonds
and he got into a a bridge making
company which was what really started to
launch him and he says that was his pet
of all businesses because during the
Civil War
iron bridges were in huge demand due to
you know so easy for for the two sides
to burn wooden bridges so iron bridges
were great the man he gets into iron
bridge making and it starts generating
huge profits then what he does is he's
like an octopus in a sense that with
each tentacle he kind of reaches out
with each new project what he does is he
starts taking over the building of the
railroads that are going to cross these
bridges in the mean time he's also
invested into an iron making business so
he uses that iron business to buy all
the iron he needs for these other
endeavors and it's it's a really neatly
interlocked
organization he's got going then he
takes it a step forward further yeah
they want to build a bridge across the
st. Louis st. Louis across this
Mississippi River which is an incredible
technological feat in those days it's
going to cost a lot of money now
railroad companies have been selling
bonds to fund their businesses but never
before had bonds been sold to fund a
bridge building project and they decide
that's what they need to do well
Carnegie immediately raises his hand and
says I'll sell the bonds too so he's
building the bridge the railroad now
he's going to sell the bonds to fund
this he was
over to England where he meets Junius
Morgan JP's father and sells these bonds
and what he realizes is you know I am a
great salesman I can sell anything and
so he goes Full Tilt into bonds selling
nets incredibly huge profits and he uses
those profits to now fund his steel
making
so if people don't realize is that the
carnegie actually made its first fortune
fortune as a pawn salesman there's a
picture of him here from 1862 which is
right in the middle of the Civil War
what did he do during the Civil War at
the start of the Civil War you've had
the the Confederates have basically cut
off Washington by sabotaging some
railroad lines and and bridges
Carnegie's boss at the Pennsylvania
Railroad which is where he was working
at the time it's brought into Washington
by the secretary of defense to rebuild
these lines in an open Washington backup
so they can get troops in there protect
the city he brings in Carnegie who's
been his right-hand man to oversee the
field operations
Carnegie works night and day he was the
kind of guy who could get a cat nap for
an hour and go the next twenty-three
hours so they're working night and day
to rebuild a bridge across the Potomac
they accomplished that the troops go
over we've got the First Battle of
Manassas Carnegie is in charge of
getting the troops there by train of
course it the Union ends up on their
heels and retreats Carnegie's out there
getting the troops back on the trains
the wounded he takes one of the last
trains out so he had quite an experience
and and it actually took its toll on him
he suffered from heatstroke and took a
vacation thereafter
did he ever fight no he didn't as a
matter of fact he thought he was sort of
immune from ever being recruited or
drafted to fight because there was a
particular law passed that exempted
railroad men and people in crucial
positions but he in fact he was drafted
and instead of going to war he hired a
substitute for 850 dollars
and we know from past books that
JPMorgan bought his way out of the Civil
War before $300 Grover Cleveland bought
his way out of Civil War for $300 how
much of that went on back then it was
fairly common practice if you if you had
the money you did it and in fact if you
could buy your way out by spending the
$300 which went straight to the
government but if you were more
patriotic he'd spend the 850 to actually
hire a soldier to replace you born in
Scotland came here to the United States
moved near Pittsburgh worked for the
Pennsylvania Railroad for how long he
started in the early 50s 52 and he
retired didn't retire but he quit in
1865 he was ready it was time for him to
it's a little over a dozen years say it
was time for him to pursue his own
interest because he had it he had quite
a portfolio by 1865 and his salary from
the railroad was actually just a very
small portion of it how much education
did he have in Scotland he went to
school from about age 8 to age 12 when
the immigration and that was it at that
point when he came to the u.s. he had to
go to work
however after he'd been working for a
few years here and he's now got a job as
a telegraph operator it's not a grueling
job he's got free time at night he goes
to night school to learn double-entry
accounting he goes to the libraries and
and just reads everything he can get his
hands on as far as history goes American
politics goes so there was incredible
and of self-education how many other
siblings or how many siblings did he
have just one Tom and what was his
relationship to him
well Tom was eight years younger so he
was always going to be the baby brother
and Andrew was very good about taking
care of Tom financially he brought him
into the Pennsylvania Railroad he hired
him as his personal secretary later they
were partners in business together an
iron and steel however the two had a
contentious relationship as well and and
to give you an idea of how that
relationship ended tom
died in his mid-40s from complications
from being an alcoholic because he was
driven so hard by Andrew and and the
reason why he was he felt such pressures
because Andrew moved to New York
eventually Tom stayed in Pittsburgh
where the business was so you can
imagine tom is dealing with all the
day-to-day affairs not only that he's
got Andrew on his back to make sure it's
managed properly how long did he live in
the Pittsburgh area well they moved
there in 48 and Andrew Carnegie moved in
67 to wear to New York City to a fancy
hotel there's a letter in here or a
diary entry December 1960
I mean 1868 from the st. Nicholas Hotel
in New York what's the circumstances of
this okay well he's moved to New York
the prior year he's convinced you've got
to be in New York because that's where
the action is that's where the money is
at anyone who wants to build a large
business has got to be there but he gets
there what he finds is that you've got
all these scoundrels on Wall Street
like Daniel drew and Jay Gould and and
he was expecting sort of the London of
the United States a cultured city but
that's not what he finds so I think he's
feeling a little melancholy about a
situation there he's missing his friends
in Pittsburgh then he sits down December
end of the year and and writes this note
to himself where he pledges to himself
that he's going to retire in two years
which would put him at the age of 35
he's going to dedicate himself to
literary pursuits he wants to move to
Cambridge in England and meet men of
letters and he wants to spend all his
surplus income on philanthropy uplifting
the masses he's 33 when he writes it
that's right let me read straight from
this that you have in the book man has
an idol the amassing of wealth is one of
the worst species of idolatry no Idol
more debasing than the worship of money
whatever I engage in I must push
inordinate Li therefore
should I be careful to choose that life
that life which would be the most
elevating in his character to continue
much longer overwhelmed by business
cares and with most of my thoughts
wholly upon the way to make money in the
shortest time must degrade me beyond
hope of permanent recovery I will resign
business at 35 I know it's also and you
talk about this in the book that he
spelled things differently than most of
us that's right
he wanted to spell things phonetically
he thought they the American version of
English was too complicated and and just
out give you just another quick story is
he eventually funds the spelling reform
movement because he feels if English is
more phonetic it will be adopted as a
world language and and there will be
better communication throughout the
world and thus world peace the amassing
of wealth is one of the worst species of
idolatry and here's the guy that was
second richest American in history
that's right I think that's a reaction
to what he saw in New York and he
realizes that and yet he also realizes
that he's so driven internally he can't
he can't shut himself down I mean he's
got to go 100% so he's warning himself
go back to the mother Margaret what was
that all about well he actually lived
with her physically lived with her until
he was 51 years old
till she died that's right I I think
that you know I spoke a little bit about
how she came to the rescue and she was a
driving force for him and he just could
not let her go he just he stepped into
his father's shoes I don't get into any
psychobabble but he stepped into his
father's shoes and and he felt it was
his duty to take care of her not only
that she had a lot of common just Street
business sense and and to give you an
idea when he was a boy and he finally
went to school they had to recite
proverbs so it's it's Andrews turn now
and what does he say he says mine the
Pence and the pound will take care of
themselves
so all the kids get a great laugh
because obviously that's not in the
Bible but that's what his mother always
told him and later in life what drives
him mind the costs and the profits will
take care of himself
of themselves so you can see that his
mother even her little proverbs had such
an impact on him through his entire
business career what was he like how big
was he it was five foot three on a good
day he would wear lifts in his shoes his
his chair at the dining table was two
inches taller
I had just white blond almost white hair
and at one point he struggled to grow a
beard so he would look older at because
he didn't get much respect from other
people because he always had this
babyface hey you got to imagine this you
know so you have to imagine this five
foot three man just with incredible
energy always bounding about I mean how
much did he weigh he was always I don't
know how much he weighed but he was
always an excellent shape he prided
himself on that now the picture you have
here on the cover of this book is from
what year you know I don't know but he's
got to be in his early 80s at that point
and whether when you went after your
resources on this where there are a lot
of photos available for you oh yeah yeah
a tremendous tremendous number of photos
especially out in Pittsburgh I he he
loved to have his photos taken and in
fact his wife Louise that was her hobby
and when I was in Scotland doing the
research I sat down with one of
Carnegie's ancestors and she pulled out
a family photo album from the 1880s with
all these photos Louise had taken but he
call his you call his own autobiography
suspect right did you read it oh yeah
and what year was it written
he started it off and on but it most of
it was written in the later years of his
retirement so let's you know say the
early 1900's in 1910 on why is it
suspect well it's it's self-serving to a
great degree and in it I found that he
recounted episodes in his life that in
no way matched up
with the letters and documents of what
was happening how often did you find him
not telling the truth there were at
least a half dozen instances where there
were let's call blatant lies and in fact
even in 1912 there was a commission
investigating US Steel as a monopoly and
he got on the stand and and just told
stories that that simply weren't true
and I don't think you can say that that
it always dude it just being an older
man who had forgotten the facts you say
he was a self-proclaimed pacifist what
evidence do you have of that
well it you have to go back to the
spanish-american war 1898 and he joined
the anti-imperialist movement they
because there was a great concern that
that once we won that war we were going
to take over the Philippines Cuba Puerto
Rico and impose ourselves on them so
there's this anti-imperialist movement
he becomes a leader and he wrote letters
to anyone who would listen from you know
Roosevelt to the other presidents in
that period of time and these are
letters with language you would not
believe I mean if you read a letter that
was written by a businessman today to
George Bush that had these kind of this
kind of language the you know he's
calling presidents bubbleheads basically
and cowardly and spineless and you've
got to leave the Philippines alone so
there's plenty of evidence that he was a
pacifist he also wanted arbitration
treaties with with all the other
European countries especially England
Germany France so that there would never
be war he wanted everything arbitrated
regardless of what it was and of course
roosevelt who who was a jingoist just
could not buy into this at all how much
money did he make off of war it's hard
to say but he claimed millions it is
letters to his partners let's go back to
1898 it while he's proclaiming himself a
pacifist and promoting the
anti-imperialist movement he's urging
his managers in Pittsburgh to build a
projectiles mill the projectiles to go
into cannons because you don't want to
build cannons because you only build one
cannon but it will fire 100 projectiles
let's say so cannons where projectiles
were in because there were greater
profits in that so when you look at that
and again this is why I love exploring a
character like this you've got to wonder
what is he thinking because obviously
prophets were ruling over ideology at
this point earlier we were talking about
what he did with his money you didn't
mention the Carnegie Endowment for
international endowment
well from the island for international
peace or that's right
what is that well that that was founded
in 1910 and what he wanted to do was use
it as an educational institution to
educate people on the drawbacks of war
for example if there was a there was a
war on the Balkans they analyzed it and
said look this is what happened this is
what you could have done to prevent it
however when that foundation was created
it was really ridiculed in the press
because he gave ten million dollars to
them they said what are you going to do
with ten million dollars in the name of
peace are they living off that endowment
today oh yeah
yes matter of fact they're active right
now so what do you think I mean is does
anybody ever go over this business that
he made a lot of his money from war he
said he was a pacifist he didn't fight
in the Civil War he paid not to fight in
the Civil War gave money for an
endowment for peace that they're still
living on today and they wouldn't have
the money today if it hadn't been for
war and the whole steel business in the
first place right well what I say at the
beginning of the book is that you've got
to think of Carnegie as a flawed
Shakespearean hero and and he thought
the world was a stage and while he was
on that stage he wore a number of masks
and I just don't think you can reconcile
those mass and and again this is good it
we got to go back to his childhood and
look at something here when he was
growing up his family were political
radicals they were the working class
they were fighting for the right to vote
the right to own land better working
conditions
better wages okay so he's got this
radical side of him now he goes to the
United States and there he embraces
capitalism he becomes a rabid Republican
so this is in complete opposition to his
ancestors and I think what you have
through his whole life are these two
sides and conflict fighting each other
and I think you can just use that it
seems opal or oversimplified but you can
use that to explain a lot of his
contradictory behavior that's here I've
got the right year or the right
candidate but I remember you saying at
one point that in like 1912 when William
Howard Taft was running against Woodrow
Wilson and Theodore Roosevelt that JP
Morgan John Rockefeller and Carnegie
gave two hundred fifty thousand dollars
each to these president that two
attacked am i right about that I think
it was William McKinley was was the
first president they supported with a
huge amount of money for tariff
protection by the time Taft was running
against Roosevelt Taft had already been
in office for four years and he had
bungled the the treaties Carnegie wanted
and there was a falling out and and
Roosevelt and Carnegie had a falling out
even before he entered the picture the
reason I bring it up and whatever did
they give that much money back then oh
yeah two hundred two thousand gift but
if you project that up to now that's in
the millions that's huge right it and
and today you know there's an outcry
against big money invading politics and
and it was no different 100 years ago in
fact
Carnegie in the Morgans of the world
back then were constantly dinner guests
at the White House and and they had a
lot at stake because back then the
tariff which which put a duty on imports
into our country could it depending on
how high that tariff is it meant
millions to these industrialists so go
back to the fact that he left the
Pennsylvania Railroad in
you don't remember the year be 65 65
what did he do then well he's got his
bridge-building concern I mentioned he's
got an iron business he's also got a
sleeping car business he's invested in
you say he tried to take credit for the
sleeping car it wasn't his that's right
that's right
the inventor or one of the inventors of
the sleeping car came to the
Pennsylvania Railroad because the
president Edgar Thompson was was big
into investing in new technology and he
came directly to Thompson however
somehow Carnegie twisted the story that
that this inventor Woodruff came to
Carnegie because he saw him on a train
was introduced to him said basically hey
can you get me in the door at the
Pennsylvania Railroad and then I include
some letters in there where Woodruff
completely denies Carnegie's version of
events and in fact Carnegie doesn't
refute Woodruff's version of the events
so you got to believe Woodruff however
when I talk about some of his writing
being suspect even after that point
Carnegie keeps his version for his
autobiography and some later essays he
wrote you were about to tell us how he
got involved in steel steel this is a
great story because it has sort of
Machiavellian intrigue to it in the
years 1861 and a friend a boyhood friend
of his has become a partner in iron
business with two barbarian brothers
they have a falling-out and they invite
Carnegie to mediate Carnegie ends up
getting his brother involved because his
brother is a very even-tempered person
and he thinks his brother will will
bring a even-handed management to this
company
Carnegie loans his brother $10,000 to
buy into this partnership however that
there had to have been some kind of
agreement between Andrew and his brother
Tom because when you look at the income
records of Andrew within the next couple
of years the money he's making off this
iron enterprise is not interest on a
loan it's a tremendous amount of money
so before you know it Carnegie is in the
door he he actually ends up starting a
rival iron business because because of
trouble with the other company his
friend finally drops out of this company
and Tom Andrew says Eric come on we'll
start our own iron business so now he's
competing with his brother Tom over here
and he's got to mill up the river here
and it's like the divide and conquer
scenario this mill with Tom needs
Andrews sales capabilities this mill
here that Andrews running needs the
Barbarian brothers mechanical skills so
they end up merging when they emerge
Andrew eventually has the majority of
the business interests so now he's got
this iron business going and it's
incredibly profitable especially during
the Civil War and the years after with
the railroad boom now we get to the
1870s and Steel has been around for over
ten years
so so Carnegie was not a pioneer in
steel which is another legend that needs
to be dismissed he had been monitoring
it very carefully by the 1870s they've
worked out a lot of the the problems in
the manufacturing of steel and and in a
quote from Carnegie's pioneering don't
pay and that's where it comes from so
now he's determined to build in the most
advanced steel meal ever which he does
just outside of Pittsburgh and he hires
this guy Holly who's already built
several steel mills is the most
experienced because he always always
always only wants the best men that's
when when feather and his cap he always
hired only the best and he gives Holly
carp blonde she says just I want the
best and what that allows Holly to do is
to have form follow function and in
other words this was an incredibly
efficient operation and that's where the
story of how he eventually got into
steel what was the name of the steel
company Edgar Thompson and it was named
after the president of the Pennsylvania
Railroad because Carnegie understood the
power of vanity
and he figured if I named this mill
after the president of Pennsylvania
Railroad I am going to get huge orders
for steel rails from this guy did it
work no cuz Thompson died before the
mill opened and it he Carnegie still had
a lot of respect from the Pennsylvania
Railroad there was still a reasonably
good relationship there but it was still
struggle because you have to realize
that that mill opened in 75 and you just
had the financial panic of 1873 so he
entered into an incredibly tough market
you write about the panic of 73 90 307
all through those panics and those
downturns and depressions did Andrew
Carnegie protect himself through all
that he did he did any he came out
stronger he was in one sense he was very
much a cutting-edge entrepreneurial type
was willing to take risks on the other
hand he was very conservative with his
money and so when the 1873 panic hit he
had cash and what he realized what he
learned from that experience is that he
was still in the process of building
that mill and now he could build it
cheaper because he could get his labor
cheaper he could get all his material
cheaper because all these people were
suffering struggling they'd do anything
to sell their product or to get a job
and so for every downturn what you find
is Carnegie will shut down his mills and
make improvements on them every time
there was an economic downturn and he'd
come out stronger again he lived from
1835 to 1919 when did he start giving
his money away wholesale giving was when
he retired in 1901 but he started before
then giving some away he did his first
major benefaction was 1873 he gave baths
to his hometown of Dunfermline then in
the 1880s he gave Dunfermline on an
impressive library and Braddock
Pennsylvania where Edgar Thompson was
located he gave them an impressive
library then in 1889 he writes an essay
called the Gospel of wealth where he
starts to lay out his template for
giving later in that year
he writes a second essay on the best
uses of wealth which is now the complete
picture of what he thinks the wealthy
ought to do with their money and and
from the eighth so from 1891 it starts
to pick up its pace but it's when he
sells out to Morgan in 1901 for an
astounding four hundred and eighty
million dollars that now he's got all
the money to just fund these these
incredible institutions he set up was he
finished with the steel business in 1901
yes and and this is what Carnegie I had
a love-hate relationship with him but
one of the things I respect is when he
retired he was 65 years old and now he
dedicated his life to philanthropy he
cut all ties with business and he didn't
just give his money away
he had this template I was just talking
about and he was hands-on to make sure
it was spent in the best way possible to
uplift as much of the American public as
he could now he was hands-on but on the
other hand when you look at at the
language of the Trust's he set up in the
foundations he always gave his trustees
a free hand and at anytime they could
vote to change the direction this
institution could take so he was also
very broad-minded when he did this now
when you look at when you look at
magnets today CEOs today I find it
discouraging that a lot of them when
they retire they either go to an
investment bank or they keep their hand
in the cookie jar at the old company you
know it'd be nice to see someone step up
in that same manner and and just go into
it with it with a template in mind so
came here from Scotland after 12 years
settle in Pittsburgh worked for the
Pennsylvania Railroad eventually for how
many years was it again about a dozen
moved to New York City lived there for
how long he spent the rest of his life
there I for the winters and and the
summers were spent in Scotland involved
with the steel company total number of
years there where you're looking at 75
20 25 years let's say and then when he
retired in 1901 what
you do until death at nineteen nineteen
philanthropy was a full-time job
involved in some of these foundations
yes and you say that he got crosswise
with the people that ran them eventually
right well in the beginning right he set
them up
he was hands-on you know it wasn't this
huge staff of 50 people it was him three
secretaries and his wife basically and
and then some advisors out there who he
would go to but but as the years
progressed these the trustees now want
to be more autonomous and and so he
starts getting shut out which is hard
for him because he's in the twilight of
his career this is this is now his
entire life and and to give you an
example well let me step back what one
of his tenants forgiving was only help
those who help themselves okay so now
let's go to 219 10 ish in there and over
in in Scotland he's got his his trust
for done firm 'ln and he goes to the
trustees there and he says you know we
need to do something to better housing
for the poor now this is not Carnegie at
all because you never help those who
can't help themselves he wants to build
low-income housing that these poor
people can afford and the trustees just
shake their heads and they said there's
no way we're ever going to do this
especially not in Britain which is so
class conscious so he says ok well how
about if we take the housing that
already exists and we just improve it
let's give these people indoor plumbing
let's give them heat you know let's give
them a chance to live to old age and
again they just say no they shut the
door on him so there's certain
situations like that that this start to
crop up more frequently later on you're
from Hanover New Hampshire had you find
yourself there I was living in Wilton
Connecticut Fairfield County right next
to New York City doing what I was
writing and my wife was still supporting
us doing what she was working for
Anderson consulting which is now
Accenture not to be confused with the
other end
and and my career got to a point where
we could now basically go wherever we
wanted and and we just wanted to get out
of the New York metro area
and escape north we love the outdoors
Hanover is home to Dartmouth so there's
great research facilities there it's
just it's just a great place to be where
did you grow up all over the place
my father worked for Union Carbide so we
were moving every two to three years
where did you spend the most time in
Wilton I actually went to high school
there then after college I bounced
around a bit we came back to Wilton for
a few years before we hightailed it and
where'd you go to college Lafayette
College what'd you study economics and
business do you have a family yep three
kids and can you make a living off of
writing barely it is tough and but you
know what you don't do it for the money
I love to write and when I look at this
book I don't think of myself as a
biographer I don't think of myself as
historian I just it's my craft and I
just want to bring that character life
with language one of the notes that I
want to ask you about is that you said
you want to thank Carol for a seance and
skeebo would you like to explain that
yes okay
I'll tell it's one personal story I go
to skeebo which is now a club the
International Club you got people coming
from all over the world and interesting
people where Carnegie used to live right
right so the second morning I'm there I
come down to breakfast and this I've met
two couples and the one woman says
you're not going to believe this I saw
Carnegie's ghost last night I know I saw
his ghost and there was banging I can't
explain it
the other woman her friend says to me I
think I think your presence here has
disturbed him and I think we need to do
a seance because she's into the occult
and I I just it I was flabbergasted at
this and I said you know what I'm just
not into this and in fact I actually had
an appointment luckily with
one of Carnegie's ancestors who runs an
organic farm on property adjacent Skiba
so that was my excuse to hightail it out
of there but but she had the seance
anyway and did this automatic writing
thing and then afterward Gabe gave me
her notes and it she claimed Carnegie
spoke to her about how skeebo is for the
people and everything he did was always
for the people and and that was that
mr. and mrs. Carnegie had one child they
named her Margaret any ancestors yes
there's still a Margaret had a few
children and there they go find
ancestors in Scotland New York City even
out in Colorado so there's quite a few
around there very inconspicuous Carnegie
gave away you know most of his money
there's not these huge trust like the
Rockefeller family enjoys the big
difference between what Rockefeller did
with his money Morgan did with his money
and Carnegie did with his money Morgan
was a spendthrift Carnegie felt it that
the wealthy should live very modest
lines right so Morgan was not someone
Carnegie cared to deal with he did give
away some of his money I think most of
it went to the Episcopalian Church
because he was the philanderer and
because it redeemed his soul Rockefeller
however actually went to Carnegie for
advice on many of the foundations and
trusts that that he set up Rockefeller
funded the University of Chicago he was
big into so he's big into education
medical schools that kind of thing and
and Carnegie loved it he left that to
Rockefeller and then we've talked a bit
about what Carnegie did however
Rockefeller did give away five hundred
million dollars which was an astounding
amount of money but he did pass five
hundred million along to its children so
all of the Rockefellers and Nelsons and
the David's and the Lawrence's and all
got money from the family and even
beyond one big chapter here is the
Homestead tragedy in the middle of all
this in the middle of the steel business
what was the Homestead tragedy and what
impact did it have on mr. Carnegie the
Homestead tragedy took place in the
summer of 1892 when the workers
there went on strike for better wages
there's a couple of intriguing things
ultimately you need to know that the 13
men died the Pinkertons were brought in
to suppress the strike however there's a
couple intriguing things one is that
that you had 3800 men there but only a
little over 300 were going to be
affected by these wage cuts and yet the
entire workforce got behind this strike
and so you've got to wonder why and the
answers in the book and I don't want to
divulge it so that's that's one intrigue
the other intrigue is that Carnegie's
was criticized just just brutally
criticized by the press for being in
Scotland at the time of the strike for
hiding in Scotland that is not true at
all he had been going to Scotland every
summer for years at this point in fact
the day of the strike of the violence
July 6 he was in Aberdeen Scotland he
was was receiving a freedom of the city
because he had just dedicated a library
there so everybody knew where he was
another piece of lore is that the
Carnegie was not involved that this was
Frick's game I was Franklin Henry Clay
Frick was his partner he was a president
of the company at this time he was in
charge of all the operations so
Carnegie's over in Scotland
however there's communication between
him and Frick right up till July 4th and
this is where those letters that were
available in the Kenneth Warren book
come into play he was in communication
right up to July 4th Carnegie was right
in there planning the campaign to to
oust the Union from the mill so in
actuality you should be more critical of
the fact that Carnegie was right they're
planning this campaign and then the
other criticism that he was hiding in
Scotland so that's another interesting
piece that I that I work on in them in
this chapter and there's one other point
I should make is that when you look at
the letters all together between Frick
and Carnegie there was a lot of waffling
on their part
should we give in to the
should we grant them wage raises should
we recognize the Union and that waffling
I think led them to miss handle the
situation events got out of control and
you had the men killed Henry Clay Frick
there been books written about him sure
why he's another Titan collected art his
legacy certainly lives on he had such an
impact on the Carnegie legacy from
Homestead but also he was an incredible
business manager who generated just
enormous profits from from Carnegie
until they broke in 1900 so he also
though he now he came up through the
coke industry coke goes into steelmaking
so he's in the coal fields coke is made
from coal he got into that in 1871
becomes a partner with Carnegie in 1881
when in that year Frick was recognized
as the most deplorable brutal employer
in the coal fields so there there's all
sorts of just violent stories around the
Frick Coke Company but you know what
Carnegie just turns a blind eye again
you know it's that that profits over
ideology thing he wanted Frank cuz Frick
was a great business manager who would
make money when was Henry Frick shot and
why this was after the homestead
violence Byway homesteads located where
just up the just up the river from
pittsburgh so it's just right outside
still there the mill is no longer there
but homestead certainly is a he's in his
office dealing with the repercussions of
the strike and a a man comes to see him
who says oh I've got workers for you
because they want it they're talking
about bringing in strike breakers and
this man turns out to be an anarchist he
just bursts into the office and shoots
it Frick hits him in the neck
shoots him again and they're on the
ground struggling he stabs Frick
still can't kill him another Carnegie
lieutenant comes in they wrestle this
guy to the ground
his name was Alexander Berkman and and
Freck what won't leave the office the
doctor has to come there tend to his
wounds he sends Carnegie a telegraph
apprising of the situation but telling
him you know I'm still in control and
then finally they convince him to go
home and recuperate why did they break
in 1900 Frick Coke Company was always
his baby however within years of
Carnegie and he becoming partners in
1881 in the coke business Carnegie's now
the majority owner and Frick always
resented that so there's there's
friction always between these two men
they're they're too much alike anyway
you know they're both independent strong
men and it's amazing that they survive
the amount of time they did so you got a
picture this frictions building Frick
tries to to quit the business a couple
of times Carnegie coaxes and back now
we're in 1900 Carnegie wants the Frick
Coke Company to to offer him the the
Carnegie steel company coke at a
ridiculously low price Frick says
there's no way in heck I'm going to do
that because he has to protect his own
shareholders too plus he he feels like
Carnegie's just been taking an advantage
of him for so long that that's it they
they break and the the break was
incredibly acrimonious cook Carnegie
said fine I'm going to buy your shares
back at Book value we're done and Frick
says no wait a minute
you know you can buy my shares back but
you got to do it at market value which
is you know umpteen times more than what
they are at Book value because you have
to keep in mind Carnegie never took his
company public
it was always held by a tight group of
partners so now they're going to go to
court over this but you know Carnegie
doesn't want to open his books up to the
public because they'll realize how
obscene as profits are so they
eventually settle and Frick is happy but
the two men never never talk again and
in fact years later
who hated to be disliked by anybody sent
an emissary to Frick and said hey you
know can we patch things up and Frick to
set very bluntly you can tell mr.
Carnegie I'll see him in Hell where we
both belong you brought along with you a
couple of pictures of gravesite first of
all what's this one
that's the gravesite of my great
grandfather and and the cemetery is very
cluttered busy streets around it and
then I have where is it by the way this
isn't a town just outside of Pittsburgh
the second picture it's a little tough
to tell but that's Carnegie's gravesite
in Sleepy Hollow New York and it's just
a beautiful bucolic setting and and the
reason I visited both grave sites and
took the photos is because I I wanted to
always keep in mind the contrast between
the workers and Carnegie and you do
those kinds of things just to keep
yourself emotionally connected to your
work to your book to the characters when
people referred to the big Hall in New
York City almost always here Carnegie
Hall is it Carnegie Hall and did he fund
it originally he did he did it should be
Carnegie Hall but you know over time he
lose track of that sort of thing and he
did fund it he actually didn't give it
to the city it was a privately held
company however you know it was it was
for everyone to use and it was
originally called just the Music Hall he
didn't want his name attached to it in
fact and then later the trustees
insisted it be called Carnegie Hall
because that would just give it more pop
more respect there's a lot more in the
book it's called Carnegie written by
Peter crass our guest thank you very
much for joining us thank you for having
me